(siren blaring)
- [DRock] All right.
That can't be good.
- [PA] May I have your attention please.
- I have a bad feeling about this.
- [PA] May I have your--
(intense music)
- Find out what the fuck I'm doing
on this week's "WeeklyVee!"
If you do not love losing, you lost.
♪ Feel I can't lose ♪
♪ I feel I can't lose ♪
♪ I'm mortal, immortal, immortal, I ♪
What up, vlog?
I have no idea if the
team was B-rolling today.
I feel like they weren't.
But I was in the office all day.
Client shit.
Day after Kobe's passing.
Just gloomy, just fucking,
(exhales loudly)
fucking, the wind knocked out of you.
So I hope everybody had a good day.
I know it was tough for a lot of people
and hopefully the team
will film more tomorrow,
'cause I don't know what they were doing.
- Ho, oh, here we go,
we're back, we are back.
All right, so right now
we're checking the lighting.
DRock, we have a little concept
for Gary for an IG post.
So he's about a head out of the office
in about five to 10 minutes.
We're hoping to grab him on the way out.
Take a picture like this,
(camera clicks)
edit it a little bit,
and then throw it up.
- [Photographer] Okay.
- Is it good?
- Yep.
- We're waiting outside the room.
I don't know why exactly we're
waiting outside the room.
I know why I'm outside the room.
I don't know why John's
waiting outside the room.
- Do I actually--
- Here,
what are you doing?
- Getting a couple of
documents signed over here
and you know it's another day.
It's 6:30 on a Monday, long week ahead.
Feels like a week already went by.
- [DRock] We're gonna blindfold Gary.
- Yeah he's gonna have fun.
Find out, there's no chance we get it.
- There's a literal zero percent chance.
- No chances.
- [Drock] Or.
- [Lou] Or.
Or.
- Or.
- Or, or, or.
- All right, here comes the man.
- [DRock] Let's put money on it.
- We wanna get a photograph
of you being blindfolded.
- No.
- Right--
- Right in the conference room.
- [Lou] You hate to see it.
- [John] And that's why
we don't put money on it.
- Well, man's gotta go.
That's a one for Lou and
John and zero for DRock.
- Look at this kid though,
he's not giving up.
Look at him, look at him.
- I respect it.
- [John] Look at him.
- [Gary] I'm not in the
mood, I'm really not.
I love you.
- That's pretty standard,
that's pretty standard honestly.
Usually it takes a couple tries.
DRock's the most annoying
person on the team
so usually he gets it first.
(duck quacking)
Failed today though,
unfortunately.
But we'll get him tomorrow.
Is he here, DRock, is he here tomorrow?
- What?
- Is he here tomorrow?
- Yup.
- We're in tomorrow and we have
another one coming tomorrow
that we're cooking solo right?
- Mm-hmm.
- Yeah, well,
so you'll see, stay tuned.
Stay tuned.
- Hey guys, Justin, I'm the
influencer side of Team Gary.
You guys are about to meet Gavin.
He's a influencer phenom, 12-year-old kid,
that started when he was nine.
You gotta see one of his
first videos on YouTube.
He was doing some puppets
so you gotta check it out.
Now he's blown up to 1.3
million on, what is it, TikTok.
He's going crazy so take
a look at the interview
and have a good time.
- Is there anything I can help you with?
- Well what I kinda wanted
to talk to you about
was social media.
One thing that I wanted
to get on top of was hate.
I wanted to talk about
how you dealed with hate.
- I'm happy to talk about it.
- Because sometimes there's the times
where it can really get to you.
- Of course.
- And--
- Especially at this age.
Look, here's what I've,
here's what I did when I was in school
when it wasn't an audience
it was just kids in school,
and it's definitely what I've
done over the last 15 years.
I actually think you need to
think about being sympathetic
to the person that's leaving the comment.
What I always tell everybody is,
"Think about how sad a human has to be
"to watch something of yours
"and then leave something so
that they could drag you down
"to their pain."
So I don't get mad at people.
Especially 'cause they don't know me.
I actually feel bad for them.
And there's something that happens
when you start looking at,
"Hey, you're not as cute
as you think you are.
"You're not a good singer.
"Wait till you grow up, you're
gonna be a drug addict."
Whatever they write
if you actually see that
from the perspective,
"Man I'm so grateful that I'm
happy and doing what I like."
And this person, I always picture them,
and it's not some weird guy in a basement,
it's just a human that's living their life
and they're stuck in a bad place,
and the only thing they know
how to do in that moment
is to try to drag somebody else.
Because they're envious or jealous
and those are only out
of them being unhappy.
You're not envious and
jealous when you're happy.
- Yeah.
- When I see you winning
or somebody else winning I get pumped
because I think the world is abundant.
Bro, I'm being really
serious with you right now.
You have to feel bad for them
and the second that becomes
the way you practice it,
because if you're accepting it
that means you're taking
on that insecurity.
That's you.
When somebody's shitting on you
that's you speaking to yourself
about your insecurities.
And we all have them at your
age, but I promise you bro,
you should be very grateful
that you're not on the
other side of that comment.
- 100%.
And, another--
- And it doesn't mean I
don't hear them or fuck them.
Everyone's fuck haters
or eat, fuck trolls.
Mm-hmm mm-hmm, mm, I'm
actually the reverse.
I'm sympathetic to it.
I love the people that hate me
because I wish them more happiness.
♪ Ho, ho, ho, ho ♪
♪ Ho, ho, ho ♪
- Hey vlog, it's Katie.
I influence the influencers
for Mr. Gary Vaynerchuk.
If you follow me this way,
I'll show you what's by my desk.
(light music)
First thing's first, hydration station.
It's marked by the times
so that I'm always drinking water
'cause you spend long days here.
Noise-cancel headphones,
block out the haters.
We have two monitors
'cause I do a lot of stuff.
Blue-light lenses because
gotta save the eyes.
Gum, 'cause I'm the gum plug on the team.
You need gum?
Zane?
Got some gum.
- [Colleague] Aw, you gotta--
(Katie laughs)
- Lip balm, because.
We've got plant clippers
because I gotta new plant.
It's a pothos, great office plant.
We have some stickers
because anti-bully
kindness club over here.
Initiation tonight 7:00 p.m.
We have this 'cause we were sent this
and zero are given.
(duck quacks)
Oh, May and I like to
play four, what is this?
Not Foursquare.
- [May] Connect Four.
- Connect Four, when we
need a little mental break.
Also, forgot to show you,
this Polaroid of the D'Amelio family.
♪ Ay, ay, ay, TikTok stars ♪
So, yeah, that's my desk.
Rate it out of a 10.
Now back to the vlog.
- Can I ask Dania if you're filming today,
I would highly recommend
that you work with the admins right now,
and try to interview the people
that I had meetings with today to see
what they thought about the meeting.
And if they're not interested,
no pressure, literally blast,
Lou, can you email, right
now, with Dania on it,
"Hey we're doing
something for Gary's vlog,
"of like interviewing people
"who were in meetings with Gary today
"about how the meeting went."
And in caps, "No pressure,
but if you're interested,
"let us know we wanna
interview you right now?"
That's what I wanna do,
let the rest of team know.
I wanna B-roll everything
and then if you can't film the meeting
but the person's willing
to fucking talk about it,
then what did Rogoff think?
What did Meg think?
What did Shirley think?
And no pressure, caps.
Everybody I've met with today.
I think it'd be really fucking cool.
Hi Chanel.
- [Chanel] Hi!
- I'll be with you in 30
seconds, you can go in.
- What you doing?
- I'm just gonna film
something real quick.
- So Brandon's gonna sit here.
You're playing "Call of Duty,"
we're not actually playing "Call of Duty."
- [Gary] Okay.
(controller clicking)
- I'm gonna get
a wide shot right now
then I'm gonna come back.
- Hurry.
Another easy victory
for the G-man (laughs).
Dania, for the vlog,
one of the most iconic moments of my life
is Brandon slept over my house
in 1992 before a card show.
Brandon didn't like
football, didn't play Madden,
and we played Madden on Genesis
and the first game I beat him bad.
And I think the second
game, or maybe not even,
maybe not even, maybe that's just me
trying to make myself feel better.
(Brandon laughs)
Here's the punch line
he used the Bears 'cause
he was a Cubs fan,
so he used the Bears for Chicago.
We played Madden and he beat me.
When I tell you, what
happened next, is all time.
It was one in the morning
and we had a card show at seven.
I wouldn't let him go to sleep
because we had to play again
and I beat him 72 to nothing
'cause he wasn't trying.
'Cause what his move
was I'm gonna not play
but I refused to let that move work
and just kept beating the fuck out of him
making pretend that he was trying.
It is literally still one
of our favorite stories.
But the best part was
he actually had a brilliant counter move
which is the I'm not gonna try.
Which takes out the spirit,
but I was so insane.
I was like, fuck it I'm just
gonna make pretend he's trying.
72 nothing, motherfucker.
- It's all right.
- All right, let's do this.
- Wait, you own this game?
- No dude, I don't own this game.
I own the Minnesota franchise
of this game in the league.
Find out on this DailyVee.
(duck quacks)
(fingers snaps)
Do it again, it's WeeklyVee.
It's not DailyVee anymore.
(group laughs)
- That's so good.
- So close.
Go ahead, here we go.
(soothing music)
- My name's Chanel Perez.
I'm a copywriter here at VaynerMedia,
and this is actually my
last week at the office.
My last day is on Friday,
I've been here for almost
six years, five years now.
So my meeting with Gary was
essentially my farewell meeting,
my goodbye.
- [Camerawoman] How was that for you?
- It was great.
Gary is a phenomenal leader
and I'm actually pretty sad
to not be working under him anymore.
Since I've been here so long
he's kind of just helped me
navigate a lot of tricky
things with my career
and he's always been
very supportive of me.
And originally when I
went into that meeting,
I thought I was gonna
be, "Hey I'm so grateful
"for everything you've done."
And, of course, he kind
of flipped the script
and used it to encourage me
and tell me how much I've grown
and how excited he is to
see me proceed in my career.
And I don't know how much
you guys see of Gary,
but he's just such a genuine leader.
And that's something you
don't come across often,
because he's so sharp, but
he's got such a soft heart
and I think a lot of people
see the content side of him
that's super rough, and hard, and raw.
But he has this ability when
you get one-on-one with him,
he really sincerely cares about
what you're going through.
So I've learned a lot from him
and I hope to bring that to my next job.
(soothing music)
- [Man With Scarf] So the
party that I sent my cousin to,
that one, he didn't know
how to manage it well.
It broke down.
so how do you manage,
you can't be in two
spots at the same time,
so how do you manage to deal
with a lot of things at once?
- By knowing it might happen.
- [Man In Tan Sweater] Expect the worst?
- Expect the worst.
By being mentally okay if it happens.
It's not the fact that,
you know, it makes sense.
If your cousin didn't know how to do it,
it makes sense that that could happen.
So by having zero things
that most people do.
Not mad at the cousin,
not mad at the situation,
just go directly into solutions.
It's always solutions for me.
Every day, even right now,
I gotta real thing, this
is actually meta as fuck.
I gotta real thing I gotta address.
Next thing pops up in my cal,
I'm like, "Oh fuck, these guys."
Literally, like real life,
this is not the most
important fucking, right?
But so grateful for the barter we did.
I'm super zeroed into you right now.
And we're gonna wrap
up in a minute or two.
Take this fucking iconic photo.
I hope it gives you a
fuck load of business.
We'll make sure to use this.
Fucking put them right in here right now.
Hope it leads to unlimited
photo boots from you
for everyone watches the vlog.
And then literally, get on the phone
and try to fix this situation.
The way you handle being
in multiple places,
is being prepared to know
that when multiple places are in the mix,
that at any moment,
you're gonna get 9-1-1.
Once you go there
and you realize it's,
when you call that place and be like
and they're yelling at
you, you fucking this
and fuck you and all that.
- That's exactly
what happened, while I wasn't looking,
he was talking to someone.
- Right, right.
Where I go is I'm like, "Listen Rick,
"listen Sally, like you're 100% right.
"Like the machine broke,
like I really apologize.
"Like let me, let's take a step back.
"How can I make this better?"
And Rick's like, "Give
me all my money back."
You make a decision.
There's been times where I said, "Yes."
There's been times where I said, "Listen,
"I don't wanna bullshit you Rick.
"I will consider it but
let's get coffee tomorrow."
"I don't want your fucking
coffee, I want my money back."
- [Man With Scarf] That was
exactly what happened, dude.
- Good, now you're gonna
make another decision.
Now you're like, all right,
I'm early in my business.
Do I want this reputation?
Do I just take this L?
The amount of fucking micro
Ls I've taken in my life
to get to who I am now.
- [Man With Scarf] That's why I think--
- Sometimes you can't afford
that money, giving it back.
Sometimes you actually have
to fight with the customer.
'Cause if you don't get
it, it's completely over.
Did you get a deposit, didn't you?
If you didn't get a deposit
and he's like, "Fuck you."
You might not even get
it, you in a place to sit.
The amount of fucking times I took a L.
I didn't know shit.
Fucking learned it in the dirt
- [Man With Scarf] By losing.
- By losing.
Winning didn't teach me shit.
It confuses you when you win.
It tricks you because you didn't learn.
You just think you're great.
It's losing, that's the fucking game.
The battle scars are attractive.
♪ I'm a Milly Rock, yeah,
with that Richard Mille ♪
♪ Yeah, these niggas envy ♪
♪ Put racks on their head like beanies ♪
♪ Yeah, I crashed the Scat
Pack, but it was not rented ♪
♪ Yeah, these racks in my pants
extra green like spinach ♪
♪ All my bitches get down we
get high like a kite, yo ♪
♪ See you comin' down I blow
hoes by the pound, yeah, yeah ♪
♪ It ain't about you, no, no ♪
- Hey Vlog, it's Wednesday
Manny's cutting hairs.
If you're in New York,
you need to see this man.
Headed to Charlotte for a board meeting.
I joined the board of Bojangles',
a wonderful QSR company
that competes in the chicken space.
Heading to the office, gonna do GMA,
talk Super Bowl commercials.
So keeping busy, vloggie.
Can I go, can I call you guys vloggie?
(line trilling)
Yo.
- [Brandon] Hey man, how are you?
- I'm well.
This is, yesterday's WineText was
the first clunker in months.
- [Brandon] It was really bad.
Strong that's for sure.
- I think it's 100% because you wrote it.
- [Brandon] Probably, can
you go higher than a 100%?
- Yeah, what's greater than a 100%?
- [Brandon] I don't know.
But I'll tell you what's
greater than a 100%.
Do you know what the wine
of the decade was this year?
Or this decade, 'cause there is one.
- There's a wine of the decade?
- [Brandon] James Suckling
invented something called
"Wine of the Decade."
- I give him a lot of credit.
I love James.
The wine of the decade is a Super Tuscan.
- [Brandon] 2017 Almaviva.
(Gary laughs)
The vineyard has plenty available.
And he also gave it 100.
- What's greater, I wish he gave it 101.
That would have just broke everybody.
You know what's funny?
I feel like if I rated a wine 101,
it'd be similar to when I
invented second round picks
in our fantasy league in
the middle of the season.
- [Brandon] It's definitely possible.
100%.
- I think I need to
taste a thousand wines,
find the best wine ever and rate it 101
and just watch the
entire fucking wine world
hate me forever.
♪ Do this, tell me why you do this ♪
♪ Do this, tell my why I do this ♪
♪ Do this ♪
- Brother, before the email newsletter,
I created a fax newsletter
and would fax people offers of
wine and the list got so big.
Yeah, I got to talk about this more.
The list got so big.
- I learn something about you.
- Right, I'm such a fucking idiot.
This is why thank God we have
WeeklyVee now, this will be...
(group laughs)
Nobody knows this, I don't
think I've ever said it.
I faxed so many people
that the list got so big
and it was so slow
that even when I would
send the fax at 2:00 p.m.,
some people were getting
it at two in the morning.
And some people, 'cause this
was at the height of fax,
pre-email, like right
on the cusp, obviously.
People had fax in their home offices.
So we would get phone calls
with, "You fucking asshole.
"You sent me a fax at
1:40 in the morning."
Fax are loud as fuck.
(imitating fax machine)
People like, kids are crying at midnight
and fucking they're like,
"I don't want your fucking pinot noir.
"You're fucking waking up Sally."
- [Man] How old were you at this point?
- I'm like 18?
Bro, I'm underrated.
I haven't even, people think,
I haven't started telling my stories.
- Hey guys, it's Jason.
I'm the editor of the first
few episodes of WeeklyVee.
The next meeting you're about to watch
is a little behind the
scenes of the last episode
that I had to make.
It was like 36 hours of footage
and I was in a dilemma if
we should show every meeting
that Gary was having or
just the hot moments.
So then, this is me going in there
and asking Gary on his feedback.
Check it out.
It's like 36 hours
and I'm kinda caught up in my head
if we wanna showcase
every moment of your day.
'Cause that's what you've
been saying B-roll everything,
B-roll everything, throw Keed over it.
Or just show that hot awesome moment
and then roll into the next
day so it keeps the flow.
- My thought is there's a model to be had
where you guys do both.
Where the moments of the day,
I actually think you can
show 5 1/2 hours of my day
in 15 seconds.
- [Jason] And that makes sense.
- And maybe I'm wrong like
I'm looking at you go for,
but to me, it's
two seconds,
(fingers snaps)
and writing over it.
Meeting with answer.
(fingers snapping)
Like, like, like, like.
I'm just curious.
I've always been curious of that look.
I always think about it
as the way you guys edit.
Where it's, you know there's,
it's a long string and it's
like do, do, do, do, do.
That's kinda how I think about.
It's third, like 4 1/2 minutes
of the epic thing and then,
(blowing raspberries)
it's just literally
three seconds of 17
different rooms I was in.
And that becomes, I
don't know, 51 seconds.
- [Jason] All right, that's good enough.
- It's good math at home, kids.
- [Jason] Good to know I'm--
Math!
(Jason giggles)
- [Jason] Was I don't make
a vlog and then you be,
"Well, why didn't you
show the rest of the day?"
- Great news.
- Yeah.
- We're gonna make these for a long time,
I don't give a fuck what you do.
Make a silent film for this
one, I don't give a shit.
- So I thought that was
really cool meeting with Gary.
It showed his creative
freedom that he gives us
and how he values
the marathon of the
documentation of these vlogs
rather than every single
episode being perfect.
It was obviously better on me
while I'm editing these
to reduce the pressure.
It's just, it's cool having a leader
that just values the creative freedom.
Also if you guys have any
feedback leave it in the comments.
I wanna hear what you guys have to say,
how we show Gary's life.
And now, on with the vlog.
- You're not coming with, right?
- [Camerawoman] Mm-mm, no.
- Just stay here, cool.
Headed to Charlotte, like I said
when I was getting my haircut.
Board meeting, dinner
with the board tonight.
Board meeting tomorrow.
Off to Miami for Super Bowl.
Bunch of events, VaynerSports party.
Mic event for ONE37pm with D. Wade
and networking and making
fucking shit happen.
It's always good to be where everybody is
because then shit can happen.
Serendipity, motherfucker.
(energetic music)
What's up, vlog?
Just got done with the CMO of Bojangles'.
We just had a little glass of wine.
I'm in Charlotte in a Palms restaurant.
But the scene is epic.
I'm all about people in Charlotte.
'Bout to to go into the
board meeting dinner.
Got the board meeting tomorrow.
Headed to Miami.
Had a bunch of phone calls
about our Super Bowl spots.
We got three of them.
By the time you watch this, they've aired.
We've got the magic.
Here's some here's some
headlines or clips about them.
Team edit that in.
Let's keep it rolling.
Vlog, what's good?
I'm sitting here in Charlotte.
Just did two client calls.
Had a call with the new business team
and headed to Miami to
do some Super Bowl shit.
- [TSA Officer] TSA pre-check.
- [Gary] TSA pre.
- [TSA Officer] I don't
wanna be on camera.
- Oh no, not video, I'm sorry.
- [Man] Get up!
- Hey everybody, I'm Maha.
I work with Gary on Team GaryVee.
My role basically, is to help
create relationships for Gary,
in the U.S. and globally.
So people know what Gary's up to,
what the company is doing
and how we do storytelling
on a global scale.
So we went to Miami.
We had a great time.
We went to Radio Row.
Basically all of the press are there
and you're speed-dating.
You're talking to all the
media telling your stories.
We had three monster
Super Bowl ads this year.
So we took the time to get
on all the radio stations
and TV networks to talk
about all things Super Bowl,
brands, under-priced attention,
why companies should think about
doing advertising in the Super Bowl
and where we think marketing
and Super Bowl mix.
So it was super fun.
A really cool vibe.
Can't wait for you guys to check it out.
Check out the vlog and let
us know what you think.
(soothing music)
♪ Say what's on your mind ♪
♪ Why we wasting time ♪
- How you feeling, prepping?
- Yeah, I feel great.
- Just like focused in?
- Yeah, you know me, I'm locked in.
- I know exactly who you are, bro.
I know exactly who both of you are.
You know the best part of all this is,
I don't even reach out to guys.
There's so many of you
in the scheme of things.
Like when we go into,
I'm already working on next year.
When you look at a thousand
and you get it down to 50
before you even reach out
and then you start really
digging into, this is it.
There is nothing else for me.
Like all of you can run forties.
All of you can bench.
The variable is this.
Yeah man, keep doing it, man.
It's great to see you.
- Good to see you.
- Great to see you, man.
- Appreciate you.
- I'm rooting for you, bro.
I can't wait to see you do your thing.
- Right.
- Who was that?
- Those were two kids
that VaynerSports recruited
and we didn't get either.
And I think, actually good job, DRock,
(duck quacks)
because if you look
at that interaction,
you might think they're my best friends
and actually they've delivered
disappointing news to us.
But that doesn't take away the humanity.
I talk a lot about, on the field,
at the time, when they
went with somebody else,
I was like, "That mother."
Literally, to that, you know,
fucking idiot doesn't get.
But that's the same way of losing the game
and then you're pissed.
But then when it's over,
you're shaking hands.
Those are wonderful kids.
It's the reason we were super
focused on trying to get them.
So that was a good job, DRock.
For me to explain that,
because I think if you play it where
you look at the interaction
and now I give you the
recall and you're, "Wait."
It shows the class.
Maybe that's the right,
I don't think myself as a classy,
but it shows class and
even though the situation
doesn't work out the way you wanted it to,
I'm rooting for those young men.
They play a brutal fucking thing.
The reason we started VaynerSports is to,
that's a tough gig.
They may only be in the
league for two or three years.
It's tough out there and so
I want those kids to win.
- [Interviewer] After we
take a couple of these,
we'll go through the sides,
here are your hot takes,
and then we're done.
- Great.
- Sound good?
- [Interviewer] So, first off,
can you look into the camera
and say your name and Twitter name.
- Sure, Gary Vaynerchuk,
@GaryVee, two silent Es.
One of the worst branding
moves of all time.
- [Interviewer] Take one more appetizer,
start with the burner one.
- You know what, I need a burner handle.
I can do some real damage with a burner.
You know what, I don't
have a burner handle
but I decided right here
on this Super Bowl weekend
at the TwitterBar that I'm creating one
and it's gonna do huge fucking damage.
Am I allowed to curse on the TwitterBar?
Huge fucking damage.
Look for my burner account in 2020.
- [Interviewer] All right,
let's pick a couple entrees.
- Okay.
- [Interviewer] Anything that?
- Oh, this is a good one, what
was your first screen name?
Oh, are you talking just
in general, in life?
(interviewer laughs)
Oh, man.
My first screen name was GeeNuts.
(interviewer laughs)
Not necessarily the thing
I'm most proud about.
But if you know music culture,
you'd understand a little bit more.
It's not as gross as it sounds
but I had many variations
of GeeNuts, by the way.
It was like G-E-E-N-U-T-S.
Then there was one that I used,
I think on Yahoo! Messenger
with a Z for the nuts part of it.
We kept it kind of hardcore in 1999.
- [Interviewer] Do you
have favorite rom-com?
Not many people have asked, answered this.
- I watch a lot of rom-coms.
"Crazy Rich Asians"
completely stole my heart.
Just a perfect story.
Oh, what's that Patrick
Dempsey, "Can't Buy Me Love."
Is that the 1980's Patrick Dempsey?
That is an all-time one for me.
So, Kip, I'm fairly solid with rom-coms.
Those two stand out though.
- [Interviewer] Two
minutes left in the game,
we're down six, and driving.
What am I telling the team?
- Two minutes left, we're
down six and driving.
What do I tell the team?
You know it's funny.
I tend to use humor
to take pressure off of the situation.
And I like to razz my favorite person.
So I'd probably look at
one of the really fat offensive linemen
and I'd probably say something like,
"Hey, after we win this
fucking Super Bowl,
"can you please lose 15 pounds, you fuck?"
And then everybody would
laugh, and we'd go score,
and win the Super Bowl.
- [Interviewer] Okay, we need
your take on these sides.
- Okay, can you just hit 'em and then--
- Yup, just through it.
- You throw them.
- Go through it, one by one.
- Can you throw the name at me
and then I can go.
- Sure.
- It'll go even quicker.
- [Interviewer] Balenciaga.
- Overpriced culture.
- [Interviewer] Post Malone.
- Underrated pop star.
- [Interviewer] Anime.
- Deep, deep, creativity.
- [Interviewer] Adam Sandler.
- All-time legend.
- [Interviewer] Sushi.
- Delicious as fuck.
- [Interviewer] Liquorice.
- Delicious as fuck, black.
- [Interviewer] Cilantro.
- The one of the three things ever
that I didn't like the
first time I tasted it.
But in my quest to like every
single thing to consume,
I fought and it went
from tasting like soap
to now being something that
I can actually consume.
- [Interviewer] Candy corn.
- Gets stuck in my teeth,
yet I continue to persevere
'cause it's delicious.
- [Interviewer] Kale.
- Overrated.
- [Interviewer] Cats.
- Wildly overrated.
- [Interviewer] Taylor Swift.
- Unbelievably underrated
in the way that she
built her personal brand.
- [Interviewer] Cargo shorts.
- (laughs) Confusing
even if you think about
how fast I answered everything else.
I'm not sure if I love them or hate them.
The answer is obviously both.
- [Interviewer] Eggnog.
- I'm a huge eggnog consumer.
I actually think,
the way that we have
bartenders and sommeliers,
I think somebody should emerge in culture
as the eggnog expert and
every year in mid-December
we're all waiting for her or
him to put out their mini dock
on the 13 best eggnogs of 2020.
- [Interviewer] Baby Yoda.
- Baby Yoda is a phenomenal,
phenomenal job by two people.
The creators of it and then
the culture of internet culture
to take it and elevate it.
- [Interviewer] Awesome, okay,
did you play football at all growing up?
- A ton.
- [Interviewer] Okay, so--
- Until it got to high school
where you actually had to be able to play
and I was like I'm not
joining the football team.
But Nerf football and in high school,
everybody who wasn't on the football team,
we started an after school football game
called grub ball 'cause we were grubby.
Which was the slang term for we suck.
It got so popular.
This is real.
North Hunterdon High School in 1993-1994,
our side football game that
we played above the hill,
overlooking football
practice and a football field
called grub ball got so popular,
that legitimately, people
on the football team,
quit football, quit the football team,
to join the grub ball game.
- [Interviewer] I admire
everything you're doing.
It's really awesome to watch.
- Thank you.
I appreciate it, thank you for having me.
I love Twitter, DRock.
I also love this vlog.
I love you, my fucking
favorite dude right here.
Eat it, Andy.
(silly music)
- You gotta do that.
- I gotta do everything.
Honestly, no, bro.
- On a hashtag on Twitter.
- We should do that all day long.
- [DRock] That's what
I'm saying, on Twitter.
- Like you guys should come
in every day and do like.
- Your hot takes.
- 15 takes.
- [DRock] On the hashtag or any of them.
- At the end of the day.
We might have just fucking,
I'm literally hot-ticking culture.
That was like, I'm really,
I'm really good at it.
- [DRock] Hot takes.
Oh, and that could be
our YouTube thing too.
Remember in the stories?
- It's just smart.
It's just a good piece.
That was a great piece of content.
- [DRock] It's internet.
- It's internet, it's
entertaining, I also have--
- [Maha] That Twitter thing?
- That was really good.
- I know.
- Were you watching?
- Yeah, yeah I watched it.
- Did you listen?
- Yeah, I didn't know
you like cilantro now.
- I feel like,
you were networking.
- Yeah, you weren't around.
- I thought, I didn't know
you liked cilantro again.
- It's not that, again.
- I went to talk to the producer
so you can say hi to Boomer.
I was in the beginning but then I left.
- You're doing what you're
supposed to be doing.
- [Maha] Yeah.
- She's doing what she's
supposed to be doing.
DRock you can take a note from that.
- [Maha] Boomer's coming up.
(soothing music)
- Guys, say something for the vlog.
One of the best interviews--
- Here it is, best thing
about the WineText--
- Oh, this is getting
better by the second.
- Is that it comes out
at one o'clock every day,
while you're sitting at your desk,
wishing you were drinking a glass of wine,
a full bottle of wine.
- What about the lack of friction?
I just told you, you guys
need to eliminate friction,
you literally reply with a number.
- Two, two, two.
- I love it.
Two club.
- Because if you want one,
if you like one, you
gotta have another one.
- Backups.
- Almost as if it was planned,
almost as if.
- Backups.
Almost.
- You gave me a shout out on my podcast.
You changed my life, G.
I just can't thank you enough, sir.
- Thank you for saying that.
This is what I live for right here.
This moment, admiration, baby.
- That's what it is.
- It's intoxicating.
- You got to give to get man.
- 100%.
- Any golden nuggets for what,
which kind of golden
nuggets words to live by?
- Self-awareness and kindness,
are the two fucking things
that actually matter in life.
You figure those two things out,
everything you want will happen.
- That was, G!
- Very productive execution in Radio Row.
DRock did his thing, Maha did her thing,
I clearly did my thing.
I mean just the raw talent.
(Maha laughs)
It's just unbearable.
- What's on tonight?
- Tonight I have a VaynerSports party
with the legends of the NFL.
Tomorrow from six to nine,
I'm doing this karaoke
thing with Dwayne Wade.
- For real?
- I'll text you the invite.
- Bad bet, do that bro'.
Good to see you, dawg.
- Good to see you, man.
Great to see you.
- This my guy Alex.
- Hey Gary.
It's a pleasure to meet you.
- So nice to meet you.
- I'm Alex.
- Alex, nice to meet you.
- Dave.
- Nice to meet you, bro.
Have a good time.
- All right, bro.
- I'll see you guys later.
- All right, dawg.
- [Maha] Somebody else.
- [DRock] Where were you?
- No we were not--
- Just had a client meeting.
A potential client meeting,
with a very big brand
within the PepsiCo world
that we don't work with.
So just working.
Working with Harwood and Mary Kate,
from ONE37pm in Pure Well.
And that's what's really cool
about doing events like this.
You'll come, you'll do Radio
Row for top of the funnel,
awareness for the
commercials we're running
for our clients or for VaynerSports.
Then you'll run quickly to a meeting
where it's just literally no different
than a Tuesday morning meeting.
Fly to Chicago and have a meeting,
to meet potential business
but you can get it done in Super Bowl.
That's why these big
events are so effective.
Now run to Bloomberg talk about
on Bloomberg TV Super Bowl spots.
So it's a very dynamic
event, where you're mixing.
That's what I love about VaynerX.
I mean I met somebody
already earlier today
that we may book as an
exclusive speaker at VaynerX,
so there's that.
Obviously the ONE37pm thing
is very much on my mind.
Big priority in 2020 to get that.
Last year was the alpha
year, this is the beta year.
So 2021 for me is, all of
you, would be signed up
and following ONE37pm.
Ting.
(bell tings)
So that is a lot on my mind.
(upbeat music)
Yeah, bro.
- Bro!
Bro, fuck a picture.
I need to give a tip of the fucking day
with Gary-fucking-Vee.
All right guys, this
a big thing right now.
I have Gary Vaynerchuk.
- What's good?
- He's gonna give you the
tip of the day for this week.
Gary tell everybody what
you guys can think of him.
- Be fucking kind, it always works.
- You heard it from him.
- Thank you, man.
- Thank you, appreciate you.
(energetic music)
- Here at the VaynerSports, Ray
Lewis, legends of NFL party.
Super excited.
Doing a ton of networking,
a lot of clients,
a lot of NFL greats, a lot of athletes.
Just a really solid networking event.
This is why you come to the
CESs and, the Sotheby's,
and the Cannes, and all this stuff.
You get so much done.
Obviously in this gorgeous
venue at the Hard Rock.
How 'bout that?
Look at that, the guitar,
the Hard Rock guitar is here.
Right back there, that dude
that's just walking by,
that guy right there,
that's the Hard Rock CMO.
So just making shit
happen, like we like to do.
Putting yourself in a position
for serendipity to happen,
matters long before an event like this,
where everybody's coming up to me.
I used to go to these
things in tech, and in wine,
where nobody knew who the fuck I was,
and I would just say hello.
Hello, you know, just a hello, hello, sir.
You know just that shit
and having the humility
and the patience for them to walk by
and not give a fuck, not give a fuck.
'Cause I knew what the score was gonna be.
When you know what the score's gonna be,
you're not worried about
what the crowds say.
And so that's how I live it,
and it's still happening right now.
Please understand it's
still happening right now.
I'm just getting fucking started.
99% don't know.
I do.
AJ V., AJ's in the 1% that knows.
I was just telling them that 99%
don't really understand what's happening.
- In general?
- Yeah.
- Agreed, agreed.
- I'm always, you know what
I mean, checking shit out.
- Blooming.
- I'm like man,
I love this fucking guy, man.
- Thank you, fam.
- No, no, 'cause man, you
give it to them real bro,
you know what I'm saying?
- With good intent.
- Yeah.
- I'm not trying to hurt feelings.
I'm trying to get people to win.
The world's abundant.
I'm gonna eat regardless.
But there's so much other fucking food.
I want you just to eat.
- I fucking love you bro.
Hold up.
- Thank you bro.
- Yo man, I just ran into my man.
My man, Gary, man, tell them Gary.
- We're talking about meals out here.
- That's right,
he's going to fucking eat.
- We're talking.
- There's an abundance.
I just want people to eat.
I ate, I'm gonna continue to eat.
- I fucking love this guy, yo.
- He's like you shoot it straight.
I'm like with good intent,
'cause I want you to eat, fucking eat.
- Right, right.
Yo, my man, Gary, gonna
eat regardless, baby.
You got to get that fucking money man.
Let's win, baby.
- And on some real shit,
get that happiness.
That money's gonna be,
you get happy, it can get
real, real, real good.
I got nothing but friends
with money that are miserable.
(man laughs)
Find that happiness.
We're in Miami.
- Doing "Fox & Friends."
- All right.
- 7:40 a.m.
- That's right.
- On the strip.
On the beach strip,
where all the studios are.
- Look at that sun rise.
- Look at that DRock.
- Yeah DRock get that shot.
- It's good stuff.
- I like her. (laughs)
- Nice shot DRock.
Gotta talk about the Super Bowl spots.
So it's big day.
We got GMA, we got "Fox & Friends."
Just got a ton of media.
Bloomberg TV yesterday.
We're gonna have something
for Monday morning.
When's GMA airing?
- Today.
- I know, what time, do you know?
- 10 a.m., I think.
- 10 a.m.?
Don't hold Maha to that.
She didn't work directly on that one,
so she doesn't know exact time.
- [Maha] Wanna see the message?
- Oh, she does, and she seemed
like not a 100% confident.
- One of the really cool things
about being at the Super Bowl in Miami
is all the news networks
and television stations,
sport networks come and set up
their sets live on the beach.
So as you guys all know, the
Super Bowl was aired on Fox.
So Fox Sports, Fox News, set
up a really great set up.
Gary went to go film a live
interview on "Fox & Friends."
We walked in, Lou, Coach
Lou Holtz from Notre Dame,
was eating barbecue.
They had set up a whole segment
about what to eat for the Super Bowl
and he was eating ribs.
Gary walked on stage,
did a great interview
and then the band took off and played.
It was super great,
can't wait for you guys
to see what it looks like.
(upbeat music)
- The Sabra commercial.
- The hummus commercial.
- So this is hummus.
- Yes.
- What are we gonna be seeing?
- You're gonna be seeing
a ton of celebrities
showing America that hummus can be used
with a lot of things besides
just carrots and pita.
- Like what?
- What, yeah?
- Pretzels, broccoli.
- Oh, I see.
- Cereal, ice cream.
This is obviously the housewives,
who haven't been seen
together for years on TV,
so that's gonna cause that
fan base a little ruckus.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
(soothing music)
- Gary.
- What's good, bro?
- What's up, how you doing?
- I'm doing real well.
How are you?
- How's everything, good?
- [Gary] Real well.
- A little bit of word of
success energy talk about it,
say something about it.
- It's all patience bro.
- Patience?
- Everybody just wants shit too fast.
- Right.
- That's what fucks up
every single person.
- Absolutely.
- If they just slowed it down
and didn't hear any of these people.
It's just fucking patience.
- Patience is all that we need right now.
- It's fucking always.
- Hey Gary.
- Yes, sir.
- How are you man?
- I'm really well, bro.
How are you?
- Good.
One of the better creative
minds in the world
that we were just talking about.
Started @FuckJerry, the very
famous Instagram account.
But beyond that, talent
for the real world.
- [Elliot] Have you seen what we're doing?
- Have you seen my post
where I held up a sign
and it said something, did you
see that on Instagram or no?
- [Man In Pink Shirt] Yes, I did.
- That was a nod to what they did.
They created an account,
you notice how I never tag anybody
but I tagged in my post, dude with sign.
- [Elliot] Created that.
- Listen to me.
- The tequila.
- I'm telling you, I know this world.
You know I know.
There's very few people I give credit to
'cause it's a hard game that we play.
Dude knows.
- Tell me how to save my life,
tell me how I'ma save my life.
- I'ma tell you right now, Will.
I'ma tell you right now, my guy.
How are you?
(Will laughs)
It's great to see you fam.
- Yo, it's good to see you too bro.
- You doing well?
- I feel like I just saw you yesterday
'cause I follow you, that's why.
- I miss you, bro.
You good?
Say what's up to my partner Ryan.
- How you doing?
- Pleasure.
- I love these--
- You remember, DRock?
- Yeah, good to see you bro.
I love when people come up
to you and ask you like, yo,
tell me what I'm doing wrong.
(laughs) It's just amazing.
- I gotta like analyze it in seconds.
- No context.
- Yeah, no context.
- [Ryan] What do I do now?
- What are you doing?
- So I'm here, we're performing
here tonight at nine.
- Right after our event.
- I know they are.
- And then I'm here launching,
how long are you in the hotel for?
- I'm here, 'cause we have
an event with Dwayne Wade.
The karaoke thing, from
6:00 to 9:00, today.
- Here?
- Before you.
- It's right before you go on.
- Oh shit.
- Come and hang.
- We wanted you to fucking MC.
(Gary laughs)
- Can you and Dwayne Wade come
and see me and J Balvin's
product that we're launching?
- Right after?
- No, just anytime,
anytime here at the hotel.
- I'm here until six.
(phone ringing)
- All right, I'll hit you, I'll hit you.
- Text me.
- Wait, wait.
Let me verify that I have your new one.
- I don't have a new one.
You got it because you've
hit me up the other day.
Let me see if I...
We are prepping for the big event.
The ONE37 karaoke event with Dwayne Wade.
Super excited.
Right now, we're shooting
some influencer stuff
and different campaign
work on the ONE37 side
and everyone's prepping for
a couple hours from now.
On the actual event, I'll be judging.
If you know anything about
my judging capabilities,
I will not be pushed over by the talent.
I don't care how much
I like them as a human.
the crowd likes them.
I will be making my fucking judgment
on their talents on the yo-ke,
better known as karaoke.
- [DRock] (laughs) On the yo-ke.
♪ Hey hey hey hey hey ♪
♪ Girl can you take it ♪
♪ Yeah, she take dick ♪
♪ Never running, take it ♪
♪ Body right, fitness ♪
♪ More than a mistress ♪
♪ She made me miss it ♪
♪ She didn't want to lick
it, let's go let's go ♪
♪ I don't know her whole name ♪
♪ I just met her one day ♪
♪ And I gave her nicknames ♪
♪ And I chased the whole scenery ♪
(siren blaring)
- [PA] May I have your attention please.
- I have a bad feeling about this.
- [PA] May I have your attention--
(upbeat music)
- We have time now, so you can look.
(group laughs)
- You have a Jets tatt?
Let's fucking go.
Notice how I knew exactly
what he was gonna show me?
I fucking love that bro.
- I knew you would.
- I fucking knew it.
- Can I take a naked pic?
- Got a little heat.
A little Dr. Dre, what?
I gotta put this in the office.
Don't direct me here.
- And talented, that's a good situation.
I mean I know.
(laughs) I'm kidding,
I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
- [Woman] I mean it's
definitely unplugged,
so you can definitely hear.
- This is really awkward.
(woman laughs)
- I thought your favorite meme was
when Dustin's always got
technical difficulties
and we're always four minutes
behind on the podcast, Dustin.
I know you made a big appearance
for being super attractive
on episode one or two.
But this shit fucking
has got to get tight.
I swallow every piece of gum.
- What?
- Excuse me.
- I've swallowed every piece of gum
that I've ever chewed in my life.
- [Woman] How big is that--
- Nobody and I mean nobody, vlog,
takes better bathroom selfies than me.
(tongue clicks)
Vlog, if you think I knew
that El Paso and San Antonio
were nine hours apart, you're nuts.
I thought they were super close.
- [DRock] Sorry guys.
- No problem.
- How are you?
- How's your run going?
- Good, I do it I'm one of the,
hey baby, I did change my life.
You rock, I really like you man.
- Thank you. (laughs)
She's pumped.
She was...
I know.
- [Maha] After you were, she was--
- Yes sir.
- Do I know you?
- You do, I'm Gary.
- Very nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you, mate.
- [Man In Stripe Shirt]
I heard from you before.
- Thank you man.
- [DRock] You do.
- You do.
You like that answer?
Do I know you?
You do.
- You do.
(Gary laughs)
- Just a good answer.
(energetic music)
- We're trying to make a video.
Do you wanna be on video?
Are you interested in being on video, sir?
Okay have a good day.
Basically we work on a team
where we create videos.
Dangit, I closed it out.
He does like motivational stuff.
- [Man] Stop giving a fuck
what other people think.
- Oh my god, I see a man,
I'm gonna approach him
(upbeat music)
Now he's walking away.
He's moving way too fast.
Follow him, follow him.
All right, I'm in the same,
okay, he's moving away.
Excuse me, do you have one second?
Do you have one second?
Or, are you--
- No.
- Super busy, all right, see you.
Okay, didn't work.
It's not working.
This ain't working.
Now I'm finally seeing
how harsh New Yorkers are.
I'm not interested, but,
rejection.
These guys, no nevermind.
Let's go outside.
Oh my god, so cold, oh,
I feel it, ah, my bones.
Do you know Gary Vee?
♪ We're going on the trip ♪
♪ On a very rocket ship ♪
♪ Gonna do this ♪
Oh, oh, no, he's walking.
Oh, he got long legs.
Oh no, he's going fast.
Okay, can't catch up.
Damn it, Gary, you got 7.6 million,
almost eight million followers
and none of them are here.
What the,
then why don't we just do it
in the office with everyone?
- [Camerawoman] We can.
- Damnit, we're just gonna keep walking.
Man, where do we find loud people
that just wanna be on camera?
Are we not approaching them the right way?
♪ Don't be suspicious,
don't be suspicious ♪
Maybe we're just not doing it right.
Maybe, maybe we secretly film them.
- [Camerawoman] That's illegal!
- Oh, okay, nevermind.
Maybe, how much we, got
like six homies now.
- [Camerawoman] I think so, yeah.
- That's nice.
Wow, hard work pays off.
- [Camerawoman] I'm giving
all of this to Jason
for the WeeklyVee.
- Do not.
Hee, hee, hee.
Look at them, I'm going over there
and I'm like, oh, I'm gonna go get lunch,
how are you guys doing over here?
Failing, all right.
(upbeat music)